okay good morning everyone we'll open up
uh there's some uh Community hearings uh
first bill House Bill 146 related
closure of state liquor stores and Dan
are you going to introduce this then
okay
more gooder
okay uh representative district 9
representing uh representative leishman
who's unable to be here this morning
House Bill 46 146 is really very simple
it asks that the Liquor Commission prior
to closing any existing store notify the
the fiscal committee uh having been a
member of the fiscal committee for about
two decades I've got great familiarity
uh where we review all the audit reports
we have uh Financial oversight of all
agencies as well as receive and expend
uh funds roughly responsible for about a
billion dollars off budget uh during the
overall times the primary part is we
receive all audits and those are
reported out of the fiscal committee to
the appropriate committees and we also
recommend legislation based on those
audits uh one of the other sponsors of
the bill representative Rosenwald was
distressed and she has subbed on fiscal
that a liquor store in downtown
Nashville was closed without any kind of
a notification it appears that the
Liquor Commission believes since they
are an Enterprise fund that they may not
have to answer certain issues and they
will tell you or likely to tell you that
they have to respond rapid fire to
either acquire a lease cancel a lease
make an agreement or whatever
here's the facts
they know what the lease is ending way
in advance
and if they don't somebody needs to be
replaced
they negotiate leases usually well in
advance and if they don't that's another
issue
but the simple fact is fiscal meets
every single month
timelines are not very difficult here
and there needs to be oversight of every
agency fiscal is the agency that does
that
this is not rocket science and I would
ask for your support of House Bill 146 I
will be happy to answer any questions
you may have and I thank representative
Senator Rosenwald will be here at some
point as well
great do we have questions from the
committee members yeah representative
Burroughs
just thank you for taking my question
um I'm assuming that one of the reasons
that fiscal needs this information is
because it could have uh impact on the
budget and that you need to make
adjustments um accordingly is that true
that's absolutely true you need to make
it well you need to have the foresight
of me how it may or may not affect the
budget or whether
there is sound reasoning for the closure
uh it's understandable that Liquor
Commission may want to have a Superstore
somewhere in that area but if they also
have a central store that is showing a
profit is there a legitimate reason for
closing it uh just an overview of the
legitimacy and the logic behind their
decisions thank you
other questions to the community to
represent me I see here it says uh
approval
so what is fiscal committee's uh
parameters in true in terms of of
approving it what would their guidelines
and be about what they would approve and
not approve
uh fiscal soundness of the decision does
it make sense
is it going to benefit the budget or is
it going to be a detriment to the budget
and I think certainly local politics are
going to have some play if nothing else
notification I know that the frustration
was with Nashua was
they didn't know about it until it was
over
uh both the constituency and the
legislative Representatives
fiscal makes decisions based on finance
and soundness every single month in the
parameter of the entire state government
this would be nothing new and we deal
regularly with with the Liquor
Commission the reason I ask that because
my memory was though it used to be this
way and then we made that decision not
to do it because we really wanted to
have the responsibility put upon the
commission to make those decisions and
so just
just a a timing thing like being gee I
wish I had known ahead of time doesn't
seem like a real excuse or real
reasoning uh I mean I'd say that well uh
I understand the economic piece but like
you said it's politics now and and
politics is don't we want to take
politics out of that decision
I think any decision is going to have
politics in it in this building no
matter what happens but it still comes
down to basic economic soundness fiscal
committee should be aware of the
long range and short-range production of
the Liquor Commission and I will tell
you that um
there have been numerous times
Enterprise fund be damned yes they're an
Enterprise fund
that the Primacy of the legislature
should hold in overseeing overviewing
and deciding what the actual parameters
are for financial soundness there are
times that it has been very difficult to
get straight answers at fiscal out of a
Liquor Commission I think this will
simplify and help
well maybe it would simplify if they
just let you know ahead of time until
you start making plans for it but the
key word here is approval
because I just can't imagine fiscal ever
approving a closing of a store
because of politics
I would disagree with that and I would
disagree that strongly in that having
been in fiscal for a long time we've
recommended closures of stores prior
um
Cheshire county be an example and you
know as well as I do we had a senator at
one point uh some time back that wanted
a liquor store in every community and we
uh on a per capita basis probably had
more liquor stores than anyone on the
planet and I was one that went to the
governor and the Liquor Commission and
said
this is a lot of money waste here and
time to clean it up as and they started
to
fair enough any other questions the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony oh did you want
it you wanted to ask a question I'm
sorry you really need to take a question
representative thank you sorry I didn't
thank you I wanted to know what the
timeline would be so with this process
is there you know 30 days what is the
timeline that you would be recommending
for this quote approval a week the next
meeting of a committee fiscal has a
pretty much standard routine unless
there's
a major lack of information
that they make a decision in a day on
the date that we once a month so we
usually have all the information that
goes through the legislative budget
assistant well in advance that provides
all the parameters that we need to know
for information and if it can't be
approved that day
it would be based on specific questions
that have not been answered they would
be given directly to the commission to
report back at the next meeting and if
and there should never be but if
for some reason there was a time is of
the essence necessity fiscal has the
always always has the ability to have a
so I just want to make sure I understand
it so it could be several months
theoretically it could be several months
by the time it gets on a calendar and
scheduled and reviewed and special
meetings so there is a time element
I would strongly disagree fiscal's track
record is the Liquor Commission submits
the information
the fiscal committee has what's called
pre-fiscal you go through all of that
information all the details uh a week in
advance you have the information usually
prior to that and when you open up
fiscal you have that agency come in
answer your questions and you make a
decision immediately it would only be an
extreme where it'd be questions
unanswered where you'd have them come
back up the following month for a
decision I don't remember anything
and we dealt with an awful lot of very
very complex issues that wasn't handled
okay thank you very much
uh Dan McGuire as we're representative
McGuire
thank you very much Mr chairman the
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan McGuire and I represent
the town of Epsom
and I'm here because uh uh I I do
support the bill and I wanted to support
in particular my chairman uh
representative leishman
um so
in my town I have a little anecdote
about this in that
um so my town just recently maybe a year
ago or so got a very nice brand new
large liquor store right on the corner
of on the traffic circle yes uh the
corner of Route 28th and route 4. and
and the town I I currently only rep due
to redistricting I only represent Epsom
but previously I'd also represented the
town of Pittsfield next door and that
town used to have a very small liquor
store
right downtown maybe a third or a
quarter of the size of the new store and
and the town of Pittsfield has a lot of
downtown apartments
um and and citizens of modest means and
I expect that
um they typically would walk to that
liquor store whereas the new liquor
store it's not a walking distance of
anybody you know so so it you know it's
a significant inconvenience to the
people at Pittsfield I'm sure when they
closed that small one in favor of of our
large one one town over so it was great
for me not so good for them and the the
law as you you read it here
requires 30 days public notice not much
notice but but what is what is the
public supposed to do with that notice
right I mean the you know there's nobody
to talk to or or mention you know bring
it up at all and so this is a very
Modest Proposal that at least lets
somebody who's being a affected speak to
their to a legislator I mean that's our
job is to listen to our constituents and
and you know I don't say that they did
the wrong thing in this particular case
um but at least it would give people a
way to make themselves hurt
um and I agree absolutely with
representative Eaton that the fiscal
committee does not
you know I I think political I I was
only on it one term but but
the primary consideration of the fiscal
committee is monetary matters and and
they do act relatively quickly things
are added to the agenda
um maybe it could be easily a week or
less before the actual meeting so so
this bill does not necessarily affect
the timeline of closing stores and the
example I gave you I mean it took a year
to build the new store they knew that
was going to be open and the other one
was going to be closed well in advance
so there's lots of time involved in in
processing this so I think this is a
modest bill it just adds a step that
that allows our branch of government to
at least listen to their constituents
and possibly make some input so thank
you Mr chairman
representative Burroughs thank you thank
you for taking my question
um I'm going to give a hypothetical
using the Pittsfield one that you gave
let's say that this liquor store was
unprofitable and um although it was
convenient to these constituents do you
think that the constituents should have
a say in whether an unprofitable
business should be allowed to continue
well certainly I think everybody should
have a say I mean that's why we have
public hearings right but but in this
case in in the what you uh
um you're a hypothetical
I do think the story should be closed
right so yeah I don't know I don't
personally know whether that store was
profitable or not I assume it was it was
there for a very long period of time
right so they they hadn't tried to close
it until there was another large store
nearby right so thank you
so I guess I have to admit I can't
imagine any store being unprofitable
I mean I would assume that even the
smallest little operation they you know
is the Liquor Commission so of course
they must make
that's the whole point it makes money so
so my question is when I look at this
has to uh approve say to improve
profitability and efficiency
which brings me to the question because
we just had our little hearing and we
know that the uh the labor market is
really tough right now and the
commission is really short on Staffing
and so this seemed like the worst
possible time to pass this legislation
because that their what they're trying
to do is create more efficiency so I
assume the bigger store that opened up
in Epson uh is far more profitable and
far more efficient in terms of use of
personnel than the one they were closing
and I don't I'm not sure
that even the way this if this language
here it would have saved that little
store if those factors are taken in
consideration
thank you for the question yeah I don't
I'm not saying that that story should
have been kept I'm just saying it was a
situation where the public could give
their input to somebody who would listen
to it right and make it make a a sort of
a larger decision if it was a very close
call I mean let's say that store was was
very profitable but but just tiny right
then maybe somebody would make a
decision to keep it okay
um that's all I mean in this I think
you're right in the sense that
if they're having trouble Staffing this
store so therefore the hours are getting
cut down right then it isn't profitable
it isn't makes sense to to pay rent
uh for very few hours right so you know
I'm sure like I say I'm sure it's still
profitable okay because it's the sticker
story everyone's profitable right yeah
not necessarily I mean imagine they have
one that doesn't make money
yeah I mean
I mean if it's if it's something where
there's I'm it depends on how many
customers are in the locus of the of the
space right and if you started to have
big store big store big store around and
you know fewer and fewer customers start
coming to this place and you wouldn't
have it so yeah so I'm just looking at
that word efficiency I understand thank
you
that's represented very sorry uh thank
you commissioner just a quick question
when the the presentation on Tuesday by
The Liquor Commission
um they kept emphasizing over and over
that they ran as a business and if I
think of this as a business
um wouldn't we want to
do everything we could to enable them to
act as a business and would this be some
additional step that would uh infringe
thank you for the question
um I'm going to fall back on what
representative Eaton said and that is
it's a it's a business that's owned by
the state of New Hampshire
and so in some sense
um the the legislature is the is the
boss of that business right as the owner
of that business and and and so
you know we should have some control
over it right I mean it's just that
simple
thank you good yes uh represent Philip
thank you Mr chairman this is a
follow-up question to what you just said
what do you feel is the philosophical
difference between a publicly owned
business such as the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission versus a private model
for example is what we see in
Massachusetts
yeah thank you for the question but I I
guess I I think that's pretty far afield
from the scope of this particular bill
so I I don't think I'm prepared to talk
okay see you now thank you very much Dan
thank you okay I have one more card here
the chairman of the Liquor Commission
good morning chairman morning Mr
chairman good morning members of the
committee good morning I'm Joseph Malika
chairman of the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission with me is our CFO Tina
demirs
I'm just going to give you a little
background in history on this
uh since 1990 the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission has had the ability to close
our locations without legislative
oversight in order to run our business
history on the legislation and the
reporting in 2009 the commission had to
submit a quarterly report of the state
liquor stores that were closed in a uh
to the fiscal committee and in then in
2012 they added Roman numeral number two
which added the requirement that we had
to prepare an indirect cost plan which
fairly allocated our overhead expenses
to all our stores so we treated the
profitability the same for all locations
so then excuse me in 2015 the language
changed to what it is today where we
still have to do the indirect cost plan
but we have to report 30 days after a
closure of the store when in 2012 what
we had to do was we had to report the
indirect cost plan three months prior to
the start of that fiscal year
so the change has been in what we have
to report as far as when the stores
close or for the indirect cost plan
itself
foreign and we do have to put a public
notice in the stores 30 days to prior to
closing the location
we talked on Tuesday about the ever
increasing competition in our
surrounding states and we also spoke
that 50 percent of the New Hampshire
Liquor commission's business comes from
cross-border sales
one of the things we spoke briefly about
was Total Wine
247 stores 26 States 5 billion in sales
having seven stores in Massachusetts
opening two more in this upcoming year
Costco is opening two more in
Massachusetts BJ's is opening one more
and Market Basket Spirits is opening
four in Massachusetts and probably two
to three more in Maine
so competition is getting ever ever more
Fierce uh we're obviously running a
business here for the State of New
Hampshire and we take that
responsibility very seriously
no one can can deny that the locations
that we have now are better locations
they're more visible to Consumers we
have an overall brand since 2010. we
have a logo we have a look we have a
Timber Peg we have a feel we have forest
green we have Granite facade people
recognize what we do people recognize
what we're building from the work that
we've done and the plans that we've laid
overall we're more profitable
our ability to respond to an
ever-changing real estate market is
there no one can deny that the real
estate market is tough we're not going
to lean on that but we are going to lean
on that we're a business
opportunities come up our landlords do
not wait for the Liquor Commission to
make decisions in a lot of cases
landlord participation is very important
to us the reason we've been able to grow
at the rate we've been able to grow over
the past 10 years is because of landlord
participation there's very little State
dollars that go into building these
stores
the landlord pays for the fit up and we
include that fit up in our square
footage cost usually for the first 10
years of the lease and then it falls off
after 10 years so we're opening these
stores with very little State dollars
being put into place that being said the
planning of these stores is 18 months to
two years or longer in advance so some
of the stores that we have closed during
covid were stores that we had planned to
close will use Derry for example we had
to close Dairy because we didn't have
the uh we didn't have the employees to
keep that store open it was a small
store we had planned on building a new
Dairy Store we had built a store in
Londonderry
at Exit four and we had built a new
store in Londonderry and exit 5 on
either side so in our business decisions
we make the decision to close Derry
knowing that our consumers do not have
to travel very far in the interim to get
to a store while we're planning to build
most of our closures are given way to a
new outlet location so if we close a
store we open a store within that
proximity
and it's all about convenience selection
prices but mainly convenience to our
consumers uh
the fact that we do not have to report
to the to the fiscal commission the
fiscal committee is is not uh
is not something that
we have to report to them so it's it's
not something that we don't have to do
now we have to report to them but every
single store that we've closed we've
opened another store in proximity with
the exception of two and one was an
issue with the town that was in Stratham
that's it there's no jobs lost in these
transfers all employees for the Liquor
Commission
have been moved to New and existing
locations when these when these new
I'll just add in
since 2010 we've added over 250 000
square feet in these new locations and
until 2020 we hadn't closed any stores
that we didn't relocate or consolidate
so in 2020 the stores that we closed we
closed because of staffing issues we
were down 40 full-time employees and we
were down 60 part-time employees so
originally we temporarily closed the
stores and then when the Staffing didn't
come back we had to reduce hours and
other locations then then it was decided
to close the locations permanently
thank you and one scenario that one
scenario that a business scenario that
needs to be put forth what if we've
planned for two years or longer to to
build a new store what if we've signed a
lease what if we've made concessions
with that landlord what if we've ordered
equipment our shelving takes 18 months
to get right now
so when we plan these stores when you
see those new stores this is done in a
long time in advance and then we go to
fiscal and because of whatever reason
we're not allowed to close that
particular store to open the new store
that is a business problem that I
believe that the state of New Hampshire
that relies on the profits of the Liquor
Commission and your constituents would
not want I do not believe and I have
spoken to
hundreds of thousands of people in my 13
years at The Liquor Commission
everyone in the beginning was very
skeptical of the of what we were doing
but I knew that we were winning the
consumers over when people stopped
asking why are you changing my store to
when are you going to change my store
that is a huge move consumers like what
we're doing and again I cannot say
enough we are not a standalone business
50 percent of our business comes from
cross-border
if when people get here they are not
wowed by what we do we lose
representative Terry thank you
uh if we could return for a moment to
the um the matter of the 30-day notice
certainly wondering if you could tell me
whether that is required by a statute or
whether that is an internal decision
with respect to the commission
if regardless of what the answer to that
question is
um
what is the intent of the 30-day notice
for example is it merely to advise your
customers that you will be doing
something
in 30 days
or is there a mechanism built into the
process such that you are
soliciting or you're at least welcoming
feedback from customers as to their
response to your intent to close in 30
days and if this has ever been the case
or if it were to be the case would there
be any opportunity for reconsideration
on the part of the commission with
respect to its announced decision to
close thank you
thank you for your question
representative the statute says that the
Liquor Commission has to give notice we
post a notice on the store in the store
in the location for 30 days and we post
notice in the newspaper uh given the the
reasons that I have spoken about and the
planning that it takes to build one of
these stores and
we have taken the Liquor Commission
stores out of the dog legs of plazas and
taken dingy small pakis and made them
into a world-class business and we're
very proud of what we've done and I
think if we
did a survey of consumers I think
they're very happy with what they see is
really question me and Claire yeah I'm
sorry for not being clear with respect
to the second part of my question the
second part of my question was is there
a built-in mechanism to the notification
process such that you would either
solicit or welcome feedback from
customers that would be affected by the
closure and such that the commission
would take those into consideration
before making its final determination or
has the final determination already been
made and therefore the notice is just
we're going to do this and it's done
and there and there's no bias in this
question I'm asking for information no
there's always an opportunity and we get
a lot of public comment about anything
that we do but there's nothing in the
statute that requires us to do that
other than to post the public notice for
30 days
follow so therefore since there is
nothing in the statute that requires you
to do anything other than to notify the
public that you're going to close a
store therefore it is effectively a
decision that has already been made and
therefore any comment that you receive
will not have any effect upon potential
reconsideration of the decision that you
have already made yes or no sir I just
would you believe
would you believe yeah that he's just
saying is that you know it's at that
point it is too late I mean this is a
Chicken and the Egg problems the plant
the planning has as long as it's long
it's been done so the answer is yes the
deals 30 days is just simply it's
notifying that this is coming up and and
where do you where do you need to start
looking how to get to thank you Mr
chairman for your impressions and your
Insight with respect to my questions
thanks for your help yes no answer to it
yes
would the insurance commission be more
comfortable what liquor
oh it's it's liquor okay
[Laughter]
the uh I'm sorry would the Liquor
Commission be um thank you very much
um with the Liquor Commission be uh more
uh comfortable with the bill instead of
Prior approval it said prior notice
that the approval part is taken out from
the fiscal committee that they don't
they don't have the opportunity to
approve
well
30 days the 30 days is already in a
different statute right prior no
at the liquor store so it's not prior
it's not prior to it's giving notice to
the physical committee that we have
closed a store
so the that the indirect costs can be
allocated across the rest of the stores
evenly
okay representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chairman so
could you explain to us in the room just
what is the mission as it's specifically
laid out by the legislature is it to
profit maximize is there another agenda
uh that you're supposed to be achieving
sure you yeah
no Ash a statute that that guides The
Liquor Commission is 176.3
optimize the profitability of the
commission maintain proper controls
assume the responsibility for Effective
and efficient operation of the
commission and provide service to the
customers of the commission okay and so
follow-up question for the question uh
yes so
how how do you see this potential
regulation impacting ability to achieve
that I mean so you you touched on a
little bit it would take away
potentially your ability to plan longer
term but are there other aspects that we
haven't touched on that this might
impact or prevent you from being able to
do it or better serve your ability to
fulfill that mission well uh being a
businessman and and giving Frank answers
I I will tell you that we the decisions
that we make now are based on business
criteria and they're based on the the
ability to move our stores uh where
consumers are with like Mike you can see
the stores that we've built we've built
them in areas where like-minded
consumers are there obviously we're with
Market Basket we're with Hannaford's
we're with Costco we're with BJ's
if we turn these decisions into a
potential political decision that takes
away the ability of the commission to
run an effective and efficient operation
no further questions thank you
we have more questions
representative Fila you want to try
again
thank you Mr chairman you mentioned a
scenario before where there's the
potential that you could have signed a
lease already have entered into
agreements for product
uh and then have to make the decision to
close the store due to that which could
be inconvenient due to the necessity If
This Were to pass to have to go to the
fiscal committee
assuming at arguendo that this were to
pass and you did need to go to the
fiscal committee to ask for the closure
of a store do you think that information
such as the signing of Elise and having
already entered into contracts for
product would be the type of information
that you would present to the fiscal
committee when asking for the permission
to close a store
absolutely it would be
follow-up for the question do you think
then that that would be the type of
information that could potentially be
considered by the committee when making
the decision as to whether it is
appropriate or not to close a store
anything that takes the decision away
from being a business decision on behalf
of the profitability and on behalf of
the statute that we're that we're
responsible to follow is would be a
that's okay I'm used to it
um
question
um if if the commission were to adopt a
policy change that would allow for
greater transparency in these decisions
within a timely manner
would we then be able to at least
evaluate that rather than go through the
I'm not sure I understand your question
policy change that would require you to
notify people and allow them an
opportunity some vehicle through which
they can find out about these things in
advance rather than go through the
finance committee well we do notify we
as part of the statute we do notify
people in advance 30 days in advance is
okay now representative Walsh
thank you Mr chairman uh it's the way
I'm looking at it from what the
information you provided it's not so
much store closings as you're moving to
a new location
and in fact it sounds like you've
actually only had two
actual store closings where they were
not options nearby is that correct
during covid in 2020 we closed seven
stores so seven of our least profitable
stores that had other locations that
were nearby or the two that had plans to
be renovated or I mean relocated already
in the queue
follow up for the question thank you so
when it is an actual move to a new
location as in the Epson example
scenario do you provide the employees at
the previous location that's closing
to work at the new location because it
is so nearby yes we do we transfer all
our employees no in all in any closures
and in any new stores that have been
open no Liquor Commission employees have
been let go or laid off
none
oh we have one more question sorry
question just a request could um you uh
submit your testimony please oh yes
clerk would like written testimony if
you have it that's great thank you thank
you very much thank you thank you thank
you all right this often happens when I
announce we have one card left we always
get another one that appears out of
nowhere Jim Demers who represents New
Hampshire wine in spirits Brokers
Association
uh who is in opposition to the bill and
wants to speak for two minutes
uh thank you Mr chairman and I'm sorry I
wasn't going to testify but um listening
to the testimony I felt that my group
would want to go on record
um in opposition to uh this this
particular piece of legislation so for
the record my name is James Demers and
I'm here today on behalf of the New
Hampshire Wine and Spirits Brokers
Association which are the four major
brokerage firms that Supply
distilled spirits and wines to the State
Liquor Commission
um and I think our concern is that this
would be a significant change that could
actually have the opposite effect
um of what is intended in the current
law to improve profitability and
efficiency
um I was a legislator back in the 1980s
and I actually remember a state senator
in the North Country who was outraged
that a little tiny non-profitable liquor
store
was going to be merged into a bigger
store and the politics that broke out
was unbelievable
and my fear is that this could be
another situation that develops just
like that this industry has become
extremely competitive over the past few
years if you go to Massachusetts you now
see super stores that did not exist 10
years ago that are extremely competitive
with the New Hampshire
uh liquor stores
and
um I have to give the commission credit
that we have really moved toward new
stores that are long really were long
overdue and as a result of these new
stores these bigger stores that have
been uh built here in New Hampshire we
are far more competitive with our
neighbor States we have greater
selections because the stores are so
much bigger
um and as a result that has been a key
reason why the Liquor Commission has
been able to continue to improve
profitability for the State of New
Hampshire and we have a real fear that
if politics does interfere with these
decisions we're going to go back to the
days when stores literally are losing
money but the votes are there to keep
the store open and that really flies in
the face of what we've done
for over a decade now trying to give the
Liquor Commission the ability to run the
stores like any other business would be
thank you very much thank you all right
with that we will close our public
on the blue sheet there's one pro and
um
thank you sorry yeah go and sit down I
just lost my clerk
but
okay
uh
so are you hope Berman okay yes good
morning good morning
shall I proceed uh well uh theoretic I'm
supposed to wait for my clerk here but
we're all on YouTube so we can all see
it
so go ahead
good morning chairman good morning
committee public for the record I am
representative hope Damon Sullivan
County the towns of Acworth Langdon
lemster Goshen Washington Springfield
Sunapee my hometown of Croydon and the
City of Claremont
that's the longest part of my testimony
um
um I'm here on behalf of a constituent
Bill proposed by my Croydon neighbor
Chris post who owns polyculture or
Brewery
I perceive this as a simple
but perhaps nothing ends up simple I
acknowledge that
the change in the RSA regarding the
licensing and Licensing fee for Nano
breweries
the bill would remove the requirement
that Nano breweries manufacture
beverages in a public building
the issue at the core of it is the
definition of public building
there are Nano breweries including
polyculture where the building for
manufacturer is attached to a residence
but distinctly separate entrance and
operation and not part of the residence
this is permitted by federal law it's
not called a public building in federal
the I have to be careful that I say this
accurately
um the law states the license shall
entitle the licensee to sell at retail
or wholesale only beverages manufactured
by the licensing and public building as
defined in RSA 175 colon 1.
lv-a
the net result of that is nano breweries
are having to pay the beverage
manufacturer licensing fee which is
considerably more than the Nano Brewery
licensing fee because their facility is
not a distinctly separate building
in rural communities like Croydon
there's not a lot of rental property or
other options for where to operate and
it is practical and wise from a business
sense
for an inner Brewery to be able to
operate in this way
um the Nano Brewery law was created to
help small breweries get started in the
state
I think collectively most folks would
agree that small business is good for
New Hampshire I personally was a small
business owner until about two weeks ago
I retired from a private practice as a
dietitian
um and the laws that impact small
businesses make such a difference in our
ability to operate and be profitable
um
I think I'll stop there and with the
committee's consent
invite Chris Pros to speak further
sure good idea
all right thanks um
let me get closer to this
um yeah hello and thank you for allowing
me to speak on House Bill 167 my name is
Chris Prost I'm a veteran father and
small business owner
um my wife and I own polyculture brewing
and Croydon as representative Damon
mentioned so we're one of the smallest
breweries in the state we produce less
than 50 barrels of beer annually
and since our start four years ago we've
been unable to access the license that
seems like it was written for breweries
like ours the Nano Brewery license RSA
um so it's it's intended for breweries
producing less than 2 000 burials
annually and like I said we produce less
than 50. um and several other very small
breweries like ours are in the same
situation and I believe some have
submitted statements
um online
and yeah the Liquor Commission has
repeatedly cited the public building
language of this law which is what we're
trying to remove
um as the reason for not approving this
us for this license are peruse in a barn
that shares a wall with our house and is
on our property
so they've cited concerns about having a
brewery in a residence but Federal
Regulations prohibit breweries and
dwellings and you have to comply with
Federal code to obtain a Federal
Brewer's permit which you need to
abstain obtain a state permit
we have proper commercial insurance as
well as the permits and permission from
our town to operate but instead of being
licensed as a nano brewery we've been
forced to be licensed as a beverage
manufacturer the same as the largest
breweries in the state
um and this is we've brought this issue
up several times since our initial
Licensing in 2018
um and I got I have an email from 2020
where another Brewery
opened um in a nearby Town operating out
of their garage and they were able to
obtain a nano brewery license and when I
asked the Liquor Commission why you know
that was allowed but our situation
wasn't
um they stated that the commission is
ruled that the building on the property
a building on a property where people
live is their private residence if a
brewery is in a detached building on the
property
um
then it is not a private residence since
no one resides
um
so again there
using this idea that since there's an
attachment we are not a public building
but like I said there's been
inconsistent rulings on this in my mind
um so yeah the result of the different
license is that we pay a higher
licensing fee of twelve hundred dollars
annually to be a beverage manufacturer
which is five times more expensive than
the Nano Brewery license fee which is
240 and it doesn't seem like a huge
difference in the overall scheme of
things but I'm sure any small business
owner would tell you that every dollar
counts especially in times like these
and added up over our four years of
existence it's almost four thousand
dollars extra paid and Licensing fees
which could have gone to equipment or
ingredients or expanding our operations
um aside from the monetary issue we also
miss out on opportunities that have been
made available to Nano breweries through
legislation because legislators
understandably assume that all small
breweries are Nanos in all beverage
manufacturers are large
um which in our you know in our instant
is definitely not the case so one
example is that we've been blocked from
hosting tastings with local wineries
that provision was only added to the
Nano Brewery law and not the beverage
um notably the public building language
doesn't appear in any other rsas
pertaining to alcohol Manufacturing in
the state including liquor liquor
manufacturing license wine manufacture
license beverage manufacturer or Brew
Pub license
so we're not sure why it's included in
this statute so removing the language
would put the decision for making the
decision-making for appropriate building
use back on the town or municipality
allowing for local control
it's particularly important because of
several other breweries that share our
situation most are in rural areas where
commercial property is limited towns
should be able to decide for themselves
what operations can be conducted in
their buildings and support the startup
of small businesses there if they wish
to
in closing I ask for you to support
House Bill 167 by removing these few
words you will finally make the
nanoberry license to some of the
smallest breweries in the state as well
as restoring decisions to local
municipalities thank you for your time
and consideration
great thank you now normally I would do
as a chairman I would ask for questions
but in this case
um quote from a famous play I was in the
is there access from the house into the
barn
there is there's an entrance but it's
padlocked with ttb which is federally
approved locks and permanently closed
which is what the federal statute
requires right so basically what the
commission is enforcing is is that the
intent was yes you could put it in a
garage assuming the garage was detached
that there was no access
capability going between the two in
particular the access would be by the
family who lives there
theoretically it's not your family it
could be a rented property so did they
ever say to you all you got to do is
take those locks off and block off that
door and board up so that there's no
access between the house and the barn
did they ever tell you that no I mean
that was never presented as an option
okay that is what we heard in the
committee when this legislation was
passed that all it was supposed to do is
make sure that there is no access
mm-hmm
may I
so
on the surface that would solve the
problem but since the law is not being
enacted that way
I'm not sure how my constituents should
uh we could certainly amend the statute
I mean I guess why we're pursuing just
full removal of the language is because
it doesn't appear like I mentioned in
any other liquor manufacturing law in
the state so I'm just confused as to why
it should make a difference in this
because yeah that's a good question
because the expectation is in Nano is a
small operation and is tendency to do it
on next to their home and that that you
know a customer or you know a beverage
manufacturer is usually a much more
industrial much more and no one ever
when we we you know it's the devil's in
the details when we're writing up a
statute and then we didn't really think
in terms of uh you know how this problem
this problem came up only because we
passed the Nano bill
and in that Nano Bill we knew this was
going to be a very small person who
would be operating this and the tendency
would be that they would use their
garage
and therefore that the intent the way
that language was written and I agree
with you that it's awkward that it's
using the phrase public building I agree
with that but um we can change that word
too but at the end of the day the the
legislative intent what why we passed it
was to uphold the Federal
requirement 2 which is there has to be a
clear bifurcation of a resonance from
the operation
I mean I guess I just point out that the
Liquor Commission has no issue licensing
us as a beverage manufacturer in the
exact same space with the exact same
setup and additionally like I mentioned
the federal statute the ttb has approved
this solution in fact it's what they
recommend that's why they make these ttb
um approved locks this is the tobacco
tax and trade Bureau
um so I guess that's just I mean I don't
know what else to add aside from I'm
just trying to present the picture
that's played out with us as I said
there's other examples other breweries
that have run into the same situation
and I believe they've submitted
statements I'm not sure you know what
they've said or what they've presented
as their specific situation
fair enough yeah representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair thank you both for
coming and testifying I'm just looking
at the definition for public uh building
I just added here
very less sentenced as a public building
shall not be construed to meet a private
residence so in your mind would your
space qualifies a private residence I'm
no I mean in my mind the private
residence is separate from the business
space
yeah
so if I may yes
speaking of someone who's been there
it's a barn
it's a nice Barn for a minute it has
bathroom facilities in it right
okay so representative Keller
um
if I'm to understand this with a private
residence and we take away and strip the
public building we're also stripping
some of the protections that are given
in that for people so if you're looking
at building code and we're looking
specifically here at building code from
2018.
um you're looking at
trying to make a residence also meet the
needs for a business or manufacturing
operation which is basically what a nano
brewery is a small manufacturing of
beverages
so if you're looking at protections my
question to you
is how are you going to protect that
residence if you know because they are
not necessarily going to be protected
fire risks means of egress I can go on
and on I mean in our situation like and
I as I should I guess make clear we are
already licensed and operating as a
beverage manufacturer
um I mean there's and we've received
um
permits from the town including the fire
department
um but to that specific case I mean just
to highlight our example our entire
properties like is insured commercially
um because obviously there are Insurance
questions like you're mentioning so it's
I mean obvious it's a complicated thing
um I mean that took a lot of figuring
out with the insurance and that sort of
thing so there are definitely
considerations like that but I feel that
we've met them but again I can't speak
to any other examples in the state or
their municipality
so the risks excuse me another question
further question so the risks are being
mitigated by other entities completely
yes representative
uh thank you Mr chairman it's a
clarification for me as either a nano
brewery or as a brewer manufacturer are
you required to sell on premises or
could you deliver and have all your
sales
off-premises meaning that
um you're not having the liability of of
customers coming into the barn Etc et
cetera
um in our case
I mean I believe the law would allow
either to do both or you know either
case
um and when we first got our start we
didn't have any
um public
the public couldn't come and do any
tastings at our location we were only
doing
um stores and farmers markets and then
later we added a tasting area so I guess
in um as my in my understanding of the
laws it you could do either or with
either license but you're not required
to have people come on premises to buy
it
is that correct the Assumption with
Indiana was that the absolutely would be
coming together I'm sorry I didn't hear
you the Assumption when we passed the
Nano legislation it was absolutely it
was intended that the customer is coming
into the facility to get to get that
that plant because that's where we went
the whole battle will be 1.2 pints and
versus the sample so no it was always
that was always the expectation but I
mean both license sorry yeah so at the
end of the day what this issue is that
it's amazing that we we do allow you to
become a customer you know a beverage
manufacturer notwithstanding so really
at the end of the day the difference
comes down to is 420 difference in the
the licensor fee and that's what this is
about is that he's licensed as a nano
it's a different you know the license is
much cheaper than if you were a of a
regular custom
oh yeah I mean the difference is between
twelve hundred dollars and two hundred
forty oh that's the whole license then
okay yeah and also like I said there's
been other
legislation
um that's been presented as it's helping
small breweries because it's going to
apply to Nano breweries
um and not beverage manufacture and
additionally I'd say there's also a
consumer aspect to it where people say
I mean nano brewery and some and I think
the overall definition in the industry
doesn't mean a specific license it just
means you're very small
um right so there's been something you
know there's questions where consumers
say oh you're a nano brewery
um and it's just a kind of strange thing
to be like no actually although we are
very small and we would be considered
one size wise we're technically not in
this state but that's kind of a right
not a huge impact
okay representative Terry
thank you Mr chairman and Mr chairman I
do realize having served on this
committee uh uh for a long enough period
of time to recognize that we have
recognized that there is no legislation
uh that is uh by its very nature perfect
and that we are in the process all the
time of reviewing how our legislation uh
affects people businesses and so forth
and are certainly open to uh
the process of perfecting or striving
for Perfection when it comes to
legislation
so uh the the question that I have as we
um apparently are in the process of
perfecting here or have an intent to
perfect
with with an unintended consequence I am
interested in knowing how long you have
had the padlock
on the means of egress between the barn
and the house in fulfillment of the
federal requirement as I understand it
how long have you had that padlock on
and have there been any occasions on
which you have removed the padlock and
for what reasons and for length what
um I mean when we get issued the federal
um
I mean there's kind of a hand in hand
process like you can have the federal
Brewers permit and not a local state one
so you can't actually produce but I mean
from when the federal I mean basically
obtain the federal permit and then the
state is in charge of kind of verifying
so I mean I'd say from when we had that
inspection from the State Liquor
Commission
um which you need to get the license
um it's kind of like one of the last
steps so since then
um
yeah so I mean for the to undergo since
the licensing process
um started until now the Lock's been in
place uh followed to be clear further
question you mean how long has the
padlock been on the door and have you
ever removed it and for what purpose and
for what period of time
um so I guess since we got the license
in May 2018 I would say since then
um
yeah so the entire time we've been
licensed four years the padlock's been
on the door yes and you haven't removed
it
um
feed the best of your knowledge yes to
the best of my knowledge thank you very
much
representative Gibbs
are there any differences in
requirements uh such as safety or
accessibility requirements between the
requirements for the beverage
manufacturer and the requirements for
the Nano Brewery
uh well what I'd say is currently the I
think the only main difference is that
the nanobi has this language that States
it must be in a public building the
beverage manufacturer law doesn't
contain any language of that type
so in my interpretation it would be
I guess this the Nano Brewery it seems
like there's an extra layer where the
state is having a a weighing in on that
sort of thing whereas these other
license types it's
um just up to the municipality
uh further question Mr chairman further
question me inquire uh um representative
Damon is that your understanding as well
that that's the only difference to my
knowledge yes thank you thank you Mr
chairman
great thank you very much can you
provide your testimony please yeah the
copy you're written I must apologize
this is my first time as a prime sponsor
and I didn't type it up but I can type
it up and provide it to you subsequently
his testimony would be great thank you
thank you to the committee okay and I'm
back to education
so we'll have the Liquor Commission come
up now Aiden Moore who will answer
questions
and as opposed to the bill due to
good morning
Mr chairman it's a pleasure to be here
before your committee thank you for the
opportunity
my name is Aiden Moore I'm the legal
coordinator for the State Liquor
sorry and sorry for the uh last minute
uh card uh as most of you know uh for
the record my name is Mark armaganian
I'm the director and chief of liquor
Mr chairman what we're uh our
reservation is really built around
um not knowing exactly
if by removing this phrase what
other potential challenges we face
by businesses who acquire a nano license
and then may wish to actually move it
into their home into their residence
possibly into their basement we don't
really know what the scenarios are and
therefore Our concern is that by
removing this we really have no
measurable standard by which to evaluate
an application and issue a license
um
we have reached out to the sponsor of
the bill to try to see what we could do
to resolve the questions that are part
of this
um and I believe the enforcement and
Licensing Division has reached out to
the licensee uh in an attempt to revisit
the facility
to
evaluate whether the appropriate license
is issued
and so we're always as the chief has
mentioned repeatedly looking to work
with the industry to resolve issues that
present themselves and help a small
business to continue to function and
operate within the state
so would you
like to say anything uh yeah thank you
thank you
um also
um on that note
um there were attempts uh uh to actually
go out to this premise
um
as as I've testified over the last six
years
um this is a process with liquor
enforcement licensing of trying to do it
better than the previous year
um and and we are finding things as we
go along that need to be fixed and
there's a bill in front of you that is a
cleanup Bill to fix stuff
um with that in mind
um uh as the licensee uh uh testified to
there was an interpretation issue here
um uh an interpretation issue that at
times you've seen me go
why aren't we
um and but at the same time we ran into
just recently and and I can be corrected
if I'm wrong uh but we wanted to go out
to the license establishment to put eyes
on this
um and and that was uh that was received
reluctantly
um I I do have a personal
um and professional uh position on the
privacy of our citizens of the state
um so when it comes to Residents and
dwellings and and I'm a regulatory
Division
I don't know if you want me in your
house
um to be quite honest about it
um when my job is to regulate this
industry and and that's a little
different coming from somebody like me
um where uh you know we we look at this
we look at this as we
um there could be a possible safety
issue here because we have to bring fire
in that was a great question uh
representative
but at the same time there are other
stakeholders involved here that
um to include the municipality to
include uh ttb which of course
is is the oversight at the federal level
so
um we we have tried to resolve this we
believe that there is another bill out
there that actually resolves this issue
um coming from the Senate
um and and I think CJ is here that could
speak more on that because it's from the
association uh but uh again reluctantly
nothing wanted to be done with this bill
when it was brought to everybody's
attention that there's a bill out there
that could clean this all up
if I'm wrong on that I stand to be
correct glad to hear that you realize
that there's a problem here and we need
to get this cleaned up
any questions from the committee members
yet representative Sullivan
thank you um
so one of the things that you said one
of the challenges that could occur would
be potentially people would be going
into their basements or other parts of
their house uh if if I took the previous
testimonies seriously which is the that
would be against the law at the federal
level wouldn't it would it not that was
my understanding of what I just heard
if the business resides in the residence
and there's a statutory obligation to
regulate whether it's from a safety
level or from a from an enforcement
level a regulatory level
um we have the right to go into that
residence
right so for the question for the
question my my question however though
is if if having a brewery operation in a
dwelling is prohibited under federal law
then what is the purpose of a of a this
wording as it is with the Public Public
uh well it has to be a public building
what is the purpose of that if if a
private dwelling is already forbidden
under federal law in addition if you
have
the ability to do all of what they're
doing currently because he has a
different type of license right so he's
doing what he wants to do he's just not
getting the Nano classification which is
what he wants I'm I'm struggling to
understand the need for this like I I
would like to know what true risk there
are of having this I can actually answer
this question
since I was in the room when it happened
and this discussion about the basement
came up
and the discussion was
if the hot water heater
is used is in the basement
and the hot water heater has a repair
problem
how is the resonance going to get in
there without you know having some
access into that separate space so that
the conversation was around the purpose
of this statute that the purpose as far
as I know is the federal statute is that
there is a the bifurcation is there is
no shared services
in other words you can't use if you can
have a bathroom which we're going to
talk about next maybe you have the
bathroom the bathroom has got to be in
the barn you can't have he can't say you
can go in the house to get to the
bathroom so the key element maybe is
that you know the basement is an example
of how uh and I guess it is possible
that the hot water heater for the house
is in the barn there would be a problem
okay so the key element is the way the
way I remember how this was laid out for
us is it has to be really stand alone it
has to not that the two Services cannot
intermingle so the the electric the
electricity for instance
the electric it would have to have a
separate electric meter
fund the residence
I'm I understand what you're saying I
appreciate that I I'm still struggling
though
why this only would apply to Nano and
not like why can you do manufacturing
that's a good question because uh yeah
what happened was is that is that when
uh when we were doing uh we've always
had the beverage manufacturer license
and uh beverage manufacturer license it
does the same thing as Nano which is
that you first you have to have the
federal license before you can get the
state license
so since it was required on the federal
license no one ever thought twice about
it when it came to Nano that was I would
say there was uh some of the pushback
from
let's say uh beverage manufacturers
other people there was a pushback and
they were saying you know let's really
make sure that that Federal concept is
really enforced because everyone's well
we had perceived what a nano was going
to be was basically someone who was
making beer himself or herself at home
and then decided they want to now they
want to sell it and so that they would
still be doing it at home
and that was war that where we came into
feeling compelled to add this paragraph
you know into the statute to really make
sure that that you know that federal law
was understood and kind of give the give
some meat to the bones so that's yes
it's a fluke and this representative
says it's just part of the process when
you do legislation and that's you know
this was a piece of sausage that was
kind of thrown in while while it was
being done representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um for clarification again uh
and this is I guess you know a two-part
question
does the federal law in fact prohibit
operating a brewery in a dwelling and if
that is is the case
is it possible that
anyone could legally under federal law
operate a brewery in the basement of the
dwelling and then I guess the third part
is if if
in fact it's impossible would there ever
be a need to go into a dwelling to
inspect the basement
I hope that's clear and if it that if
it's not clear please ask me to clarify
that thank you for your question
representative
um I cannot state with certainty what
the federal law is and of course under
title 13
the commission as representative hunt
pointed out because he's been here a
long time long time
um you've been here longer
is is that the Nano Brewery is was an
extension of what was a what is allowed
currently in New Hampshire law for any
one of you who decide you want to brew
at your house you want you decide this
and interest to you you can Brew up I
believe it's 200 gallons and the
industry then to said look we want to
provide a pathway for these people who
really have taken this passion and to
allow them to get into business
and by doing so the Nano license was
created to give them a path again with
limited production levels
and the separateness was there because
as the chairman said
most of these businesses started out of
their house and the conversion from a
home recreational
Hobby
to a business
now brings in a number of other
considerations alcohol as as you can
well imagine in the Supreme Court of the
United States has said so is a highly
regulated commodity and as a result of
being a highly rig related commodity it
is subject to
reasonable searches by the agency that
oversees it to conduct inspections to
make sure there's compliance
so therefore
enforcement the chief and his staff
would be able to make a to make an
appearance at at a licensed Nano Brewery
knowing that it is subject to reasonable
regulation under the administrative
procedure act and administrative search
warrants
to inspect it if it were in a home
well the courts have spoken very clearly
about what it takes to get law
enforcement into a home without exigent
circumstances you need a warrant you got
to get in there on a warrant unless
somebody lets you in
and it's just as easy that any homeowner
could say no I don't know sorry come
back with a warrant and to avoid that
rub
I believe this the legislature the
legislature put in this public building
aspect for this particular licensee
because of its path on growth from
a home hobby to commercialization
and and that's why it is there
now it's my understanding and I may be
wrong that this gentleman has a separate
lease
and and if so that that takes it into
another commercial range which I believe
is what the chief
and his staff were going to evaluate
to re-look at this issue
evaluate it and see what key thing is to
look at it what is the Senate bill
number
yeah right now it's just an LSR LSR
Lang okay
further questions okay further question
may inquire
thank you uh again for clarification
um the gentleman who testified earlier
um who operates the Brewer in his barn
has a license as a beverage manufacturer
uh but he has been denied a license as a
nano brewery
could you clarify why it's acceptable
for him to have a license as a beverage
manufacturer but not as a nano Brewer
considering that the circumstances are
identical
thank you for the question
representative and I think it's a great
question and one that I want to
I want to I want to personally resolve
you you have a very legitimate question
I don't know until I look at it and when
I look at it it might fulfill the
obligation of what is a nano brewery
and and
the gentleman's fees will go down from
twelve hundred dollars twelve hundred
and change down to 240. that quite that
that is very accurate testimony and but
not putting eyes on that location
prohibits me from making that decision
and I I want to clean that and again
those of you that know the reason why I
came here six years ago and and what my
job has been tasked to do
these are things that I've been tasked
to do and that's to fix this stuff so
for a lack of a more polished term
um so uh this could be one of them I
don't know I haven't gone down there I
want to go down there personally I want
to go down there and I've done that
okay representative thank you
please collect correct me if I'm wrong
here I'm trying to understand the
purpose of these Provisions as I
understand it the purpose of the Nano
Brewery statute
is in part to alleviate the difficulties
of the search and seizure provision for
the Liquor Commission if there were to
be a brewery in a home correct
I mean go ahead
I don't believe that's the purpose uh
could you restate your question please
at least in part the Nano Brewery
provision alleviates some of the search
and seizure difficulties if there were
for the Liquor Commission or other
enforcement if there were to be a
brewery in a home is that correct
it we would look at it probably in
reverse that if you were an applicant
for for the license we would say is this
facility that you're intending to have
your Brewing operation in a public
building
and if the answer is no it's not then
under the current statute you would be
what do you see then as being the
legislative purpose of this statute
but
if it is not trying to achieve then that
public good of eliminating the search
and seizure problem for the Liquor
Commission
um
looking at this from a historical
perspective and and unfortunately I've
been around long enough to see a lot of
the history as it's kind of built up
I was not working I'm a former
enforcement member I spent 25 years with
the commission uh the last 10 as the
chief I don't I was not present when the
Nano license was created so
um I I'm not privy to some of the
conversations that took place but the
Nano license was not created to avoid
a search and seizure issue
um
the the Nano license was created to give
a pathway to the home Brewer
to get into the commercial Market if
they wished and therefore by entering
into that commercial Market they are now
subject to the reasonable regulation
that comes with holding a license
to sell alcohol in New Hampshire
so
with that the reasonable regulation does
and the commission has in its statutes
the requirement to do inspections and to
ensure title 13 is in compliance so
um
the the statute
by virtue of the fact that it moves it
to a public building kind of avoids this
issue of search and seizure out of a
residence because we wouldn't permit
that to be licensed in a private
residence
I hope I've answered your question as a
follow-up if the licensee were to hold
out that a particular portion of a
building for example that was padlocked
off at Barn for example that was
padlocked off from the rest of the
building
was the brewery
what search and seizure difficulties
that does that hold off for the
commission to only search that area and
no other area
the
no two businesses that sell alcohol in
New Hampshire are alike none of them
none of them uh my experience has been
you talked to 100 people and they're all
going to have their own business models
they're going to have their own idea
what things look like where they're
going to be how it's going to run
everything that we do in the way of
licensure is an independent review of
the facts and circumstances that present
themselves at the time of application
so if if the gentleman
is going to get a license then we would
be looking at what are the facts and
circumstances looking at the statute
what does the statute require what does
it prohibit and then running through
that checklist literally a checklist
that says yes no yes no and then based
upon what is at the end will come a
recommendation from the enforcement
division whether to license or not
license from the commission
I someone made the interpretation that
this business was not eligible for a
nano brewery license
but
took the next step which seems to be
much more costly to get them into a
business license that they were eligible
and there were no limitations on and
that is the beverage manufacturer
license so rather than just say no
you can't get this license period
well you can't get this license but we
do have another pathway for you now is
that the right pathway well you've heard
the chief say he's going to check that
out make sure that that's been explored
we're going to get this fixed
always fix it sir always
a question and of course yes
thank you Mr chair
about
building if the built Barn is on his
property I don't understand how that can
be uh
public building
if the public is probably the wrong word
yes it was the wrong word but that was
just what we were doing when we were
making sausage
I think it has to do with availability
Representatives okay who can get there
and if the property owner wants to allow
someone onto their property without
restriction to come to their facility
then I think that would be the
requirement we're looking forward to
getting this resolved very quickly so
that when when the license is renewed he
can renew himself as a nano
thank you very much thank you
all right one more card CJ
Haynes who represents the New Hampshire
evening
please make sure your mic's on and you
talk closely thank you thank you good
morning my name is CJ Haynes and I am
the executive director of the New
Hampshire Brewers Association I
currently represent over 90 breweries in
the state of New Hampshire
uh
we have proposed a bill that I believe
will create a solution for this problem
entirely and it will also help the
Liquor Commission from their standpoint
and it'll also help a number of other
breweries in the state that fall into
this category of perhaps what we'll say
is mislicensed as a beverage
manufacturer instead of their true
intended Nano license
and the bill that we are proposing uh is
actually in LSR right now and the
language is being finalized today and
tomorrow uh and one of the provisions of
that bill is to actually
repeal the Nano license and add two
tiers to the beverage manufacturer
license which would mean that there
would be a tier for zero to 500 barrels
annual production for the 240 dollars
price of a nano current and then there
would also be another tier that would be
added for 500 to 2500 barrels so what
this would alleviate is as a small
Brewery grows that Brewery would not
have to be subjected to having to change
their license back and forth between a
nano and a beverage manufacturer at the
continuity would be they would start as
a beverage manufacturer therefore none
of the issue with the public building
would be part of the issue because that
is not in RSA
17812 as a beverage manufacturer as
we've discussed already this morning the
other is that this bill will clean up
any of the the numerous licenses that
are out there and not to over complicate
it but when you have a nano then you can
apply for a restaurant license you get a
nano plus and it gets overly complicated
in that so the efforts of this bill
that's being put forth is to streamline
the licensing reduce the number of
licenses and actually clean up some of
the clerical issues that you see here
today
excellent idea thank you for your help
modeled along what we've done in the
past which is with the other Industries
we have changed have a a light light
license and we did that with uh
obviously distilled this past year so
that's great I will further that uh two
years ago we proposed SB 125 which took
many of these issues that separated
between the two license so that was the
first stage of the process and this
would finalize the rest of that which
was the original tent two to three years
ago was to already merge the Nano into a
beverage manufacturer Mr chairman great
idea we do have a question yes
representative Herbert has a question
um is it my understanding correct that
uh
the difficulty
um hinged upon
the uh
search and seizure laws in other words
now that was just a sideline to the
whole story well he was he was asked if
he could
he said no correct correct so I I uh if
you do these other laws and and whatnot
um is that still going to be a problem I
will comment um is in my conversations
the bill that we are pushing forward we
have spoken with the Liquor Commission
and they're working with us on the
language and one of those items is that
of consideration is that no extension of
service area is issued to someone unless
it is a permissible place of public
entry so therefore a brewery would never
be issued a license if there wasn't con
deemed a public building that was
accessible to the public therefore the
Liquor Commission would only have the
right to inspect the area that is the
extension of service area which would
is he had a right to say no you can't
come in correct because he his extension
of service area is only permitted in the
brewery itself
and that's the only area that the Liquor
Commission for enforcement standpoint
the other well that in my mind anyway
um that brings front and center the
issue of uh safety
if if
I I understand uh the distinct you're
making a distinction if with the new LSR
but that doesn't solve the problem of
safety in other words is his facility
safe and and we would only find out one
day when the place burned down
so I mean I I still have a problem I
mean I would I would have just said uh
yes here's the here's the that's that's
a would you believe would you believe
yeah would you believe that you would
have just you still have a problem yes
okay so there you are you don't have to
answer would you believe great thank you
very much representative
representative post
yes thank you Mr chairman um I just
wanted to know if that bill uh who the
the sponsor of that bill is that is
Senator Lane okay thank you further I
will say with there was another issue
that um the Nano Chris brought up
earlier is that the bill would also
include language to incorporate all of
the things that a nano can currently do
that a beverage manufacturer cannot do
we've taken that into consideration and
it will be added to the bill so
therefore the sampling at a winery will
be added to the beverage manufacturer
hence why it's taking a little while to
sort through all these different courses
I've always said our laws are very
Byzantine when it comes to sorting it
out so that's great thank you very much
you're welcome and we'll we'll look for
I will contact uh Senator Lang and thank
you get a copy of what he's got what
he's working on
all right having no more cards we'll
close that public hearing
and move right into house bill 173
relative to toilet facilities provided
foreign
signed in in support of the bill
and also
Kathy Pernell
Katie okay now
Israel yeah yeah she also was in support
Okay so
foreign
did you fill out a car
no because I didn't know that the prime
sponsor had to I can do that
you can do it afterwards yes okay
you've been around before right
years ago years ago we had pink cards
back then you did
sorry okay introduce yourself please and
thank you uh Dan Hines representing uh
Bedford thank you chairman hunt uh so
this is a simple bill I put it in before
I got passed through the house on
consent so hopefully we get the same
result this time but it's simple Bell so
presently
um under the law
um a restaurant having 25 or more people
need both a male and a female restaurant
or sorry a bathroom not sure what the
original intent behind that was but my
intent in repealing that is people our
restaurants would still have to have
adequate bathrooms for everyone however
this would allow them to have either
unisex bathrooms or family bathrooms so
it's not requiring it on businesses if
businesses like their one male and one
female bathroom have it um but I think
it's better to give more opportunity
um of choices for restaurants I think
some restaurants might want a family
bathroom or like I said a unisex
bathroom so this isn't requiring or this
isn't removing requirements actually
have bathrooms and just giving
businesses more options of who they're
going to allow in their bathrooms
and since this committee did pass a
requirement that either bathroom or
whatever bathrooms they still have to
okay any questions
from representative Heinz yeah
representative Kelly Brown
collabro collabro
OK
um so my question is um the way this is
worded uh it says 25 or more the current
building code does permit in an
amendment to this particular building
code that permits what used to be 15 now
to go up to 25. if we're to look at the
building code it is very specific to the
use of it which you have as an assembly
use and restaurant
but what it then gets into is how many
occupants would be in in the place and
that includes employees
so in New England you have old buildings
my question is
um if we are to create just one bathroom
which is what you're saying
um unisex or multi whomever gets to use
it you have no limit
okay so my question then becomes the way
it's stated it's basically to 75 and
under you must have one restroom for
each gender
if you are to expand that restart and
you only have one restroom for question
mark there's no limit in this bill
um you're going to enter in hygiene
issues and risk issues what limit would
so I guess it wasn't the number that was
the issue to me it was the my particular
issue was you have to have one male and
one female bathroom I think so that
would be two I think if from your
perspective of number of people would be
the same amount if I had two unisex
bathrooms follow-up question please
question you may inquire
um
the code actually states that one of
those two may be
Universal basically then you can state
that either of those two restrooms can
be a universal restroom and they're
currently doing that in a lot of places
it's a choice so they've already made
Provisions for that
so the extent that this conflicts with
code
um I don't know which one would overrule
um I would
so I guess I would leave that to someone
more knowledgeable but I know I believe
this to be an issue I don't know
we'll certainly figure that one out in
subcommittee
any other questions from committee
members
that's it okay thank you I'll fill out
the pink card
thank you so Philip
Sherman
he's a building code inspector so he can
tell us the answer that question
Bingo thank you very much in support of
the bill and you want to turn that mic
on so red is good red is good red is
good and then you want to talk closely
to it
let me go through my presentation and I
may or may not answer your question we
can come back to it though so I speak
today as chair of the State Building
Code review board for those of you who
may not know our charges to develop and
maintain the state building code for
ratification by the by the legislature
I'll note that due to my late awareness
of this hearing I have not had a chance
to discuss my views with with any of the
DHHS Representatives but I fully hope to
have time to do that I'll start by
asking us to recall that RSA 155 a210
prohibits state agencies from varying
modifying or waiving the requirements of
the State Building Code well some
members of other legislative committees
are aware that the bcrb and the Myriad
state agencies have a lot of work to do
on this we have been trying with some
success to deal with specific Provisions
as they come up that's why I'm here
today my specific comments on RSA 1 5540
and the proposed changes are as follows
first the State Building Code requires
places where food is served to be
provided with restrooms for new
construction when some alterations occur
and if the Food Service occupancy is
created by changing from another
occupancy the code requires the
customers and employees have access to
these restrooms and set specific
distance limitations
the first sentence of this section as it
as it's currently written basically
requires restrooms and adds the
requirement that restrooms be convenient
which is a subjective term
portion of the RSA proposed to be
deleted eliminates the requirement that
restrooms be provided for each sex in
small facilities but also eliminates the
requirement that separate sex facilities
be provided anywhere where alcohol is
served
the building code has evolved on this
issue as society's opinions have changed
over time and to some extent the 2018
model code currently in effect into a
more complete extent the 2021 model code
now under review by the bcrb eliminates
most requirements for separate sex
facilities it permits them but it won't
require them
I would note that the current New
Hampshire code has an amendment as
mentioned previously coordinating the
requirement for separate sex facilities
with the 25 person limit in the section
proposed to be deleted that was put in
to be uh to coordinate with this very
section
also current House Bill 104 grapples
with this issue in schools where they're
proposing to prohibit the use of all
essentially what it referred to as all
gender facilities so we'll see where
that goes
the last section of the current RSA
15540 provides limited approval for the
DHHS commissioner to weigh the
requirements of this section if the bill
is passed as proposed the section
remaining basically consists of the
requirement to provide restrooms this
clearly conflicts with the State
Building Code which may require
restrooms in certain circumstances
I'll conclude by noting that RSA 15540
which was originally implemented in 1935
long before the implementation of modern
codes and standards it's been modified
over time occasionally the provisions in
this section are well covered by the FDA
Food Code which is adopted by DHHS and
the state building code and the
authority to provide waivers variances
modification of the requirements or the
use of alternative methods to the
respective regulations have approval
channels through other dhhf
DHHS and Building Code Enforcement
Provisions that are currently in effect
therefore I not only speak in favor of
deleting the proposed portion of the RSA
but recommend that you consider deletion
of the entire
155-40 section ah somebody agrees with
me again I wouldn't hope that we'd be
given time to discuss this with DHHS as
time for review and reflection May
identify something that I'm missing
thank you for permitting me to speak
with you today
that's great
representative thank you chairman just a
very uh quick question
um and maybe this goes to the previous
speaker of
when you talk about a unisex or family
uh facility in a restaurant you're
talking about a one-person use facility
is that correct it's not a multiple
people with multiple stalls it's just
one person right the term that the code
is starting to colless around a single
user unisex has always been a strange
little term but it's floated around so
single user multiple user uh there as
you may know there's a European style of
restroom which is all gender
harder stalls lavatories in the middle
I've been in them they're very used to
them over there
the folks on HB 104 don't care for that
the proponents so we'll see where that
all goes but the code as it's written
would would permit that unless it's
amended
any other questions any other questions
if you could provide the testimony to
the yeah that would be great clerk loves
written testimony
okay so uh one of the advantages of
being around so long I know I could see
who's in the room so Colleen Smith from
the Department of Health and Human
Services
we have has visited Us in past years
good morning thank you and I plan to
attend just in case there were questions
that came up for for our department so
we are not taking a position on this
bill we I would be
um amenable to striking this part of the
statute as Mr Sherman had stated we we
definitely generally do defer to
building code when it comes to restroom
requirements as it was mentioned before
this I believe this is a very old or
older statute before in existence before
before building codes existed so we um
we do have the food code which does
reference state law which would defer to
building code so we have no issue with
striking this part of the statute as
well
music to our ears
okay
thank you very much
Mike you know you want to be all set
okay because no one else would like to
testify and House Bill 173 saying none
we will end the public hearing uh and
the blue sheet is said nick nick cover
it's amazing how that works
timing
okay well I I you never know how long
39 degrees
yeah so isn't the next one
members I have scheduled for next
and because science and technology is
going to be here Tuesday Thursday but
the following week I hope to have both
Wednesday and Thursday uh if you go
and it is official that we did get
um
uh
so and um I I I don't like I don't want
I'm am Monday Mondays are a problem
because I'm I'm on the county delegation
until like I can't do Mondays anyways
and I and it's scheduling things on
Friday it's just an anathema to me so uh
I'm being prepared that I might actually
uh if I feel need to squeeze things in
that we would start at nine rather than
ten
my motivations is is really just to keep
us on on uh on Wednesday Thursday
schedule
um
as much as possible and then once we've
had enough bills we'll then start
scheduling subcommittees so uh and urge
everyone to keep looking at the list and
and in in terms of of telling me what
what subcommittee you want to be on so
next week will be 10 o'clock
I do tend because it's an hour
difference for me to do in sleep
sleeping in the morning and that means I
have to get up at 6 30 rather than 7 30.
you know
my body's thinks seven is the right time
at 6 30.
Fifth and 106.
um
it's
we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 39 and I'm looking for the
sponsor
anybody here A friend of the sponsor
okay
okay now we'll open up the public
hearing on House Bill 39
and hear from representative Vale good
afternoon
good afternoon
um chairman hunt and good afternoon to
the Commerce Committee I am pleased to
be for to be before you this afternoon
and I appreciate the expedient hearing
that you put in on this bill I for the
record I'm Suzanne Vale of Nashua ward 3
and I'm here before you to hopefully
persuade you to consider the bill that
has been come before you a couple times
so here's the question would it be
better for New Hampshire consumers if
paper billing fees were banned
Banning paper Billy billing fees was
likely beneficial for many people
particularly those who have not
had technology in their homes and who
are not used to and not comfortable with
for example some older adults may prefer
paper milling and mind it may find it
more difficult to understand and manage
their bills online
low-income individuals may also like to
rely on paper billing because they may
not have access to a computer or the
internet and they may not be able to
avoid afford the additional fees
associated with electronic billing
additionally people that are worried
about the security of personal
information or have concerns about
online transaction would also appreciate
being able to
receive and pay their bills through
traditional mail Banning paper billing
fees could also help to promote
Financial inclusion by ensuring that
basic financial services are acceptable
and accessible to everyone regardless of
their income or
level of technological literacy so as
I'm late and I'm so sorry to be late
I've uh
appreciate the time that you waited for
me but I just wanted to impress upon the
committee I know that you have new
people and I also know that you have
seen this bill before and it has really
becoming difficult with companies that
are private charging processing fees for
paying mint of utilities for example now
I went to pay my my heating bill
a couple of weeks ago and I gave it my
bank information it went to some third
party I don't know who they are
and at the end of it it said to me that
they use a third party service to pay
the bill
and I might incur a transaction fee I
sat there with my mouse saying do I
click or no so when you look at how
these things are really excluding people
you know we have ai chat Bots out there
that will do half of our work and some
people have nothing but a pen and paper
and they shouldn't have to go in every
situation I'm hoping you know to set a
tone even for the season that people
think about how technology is really
holding people back and how unfair it is
to have people companies that
um
charge you for the lack of technology or
the lack of knowledge
but also just they're leaving you behind
because you're incurring you incurred
Financial issues and you might have just
enough money to pay that electric bill
but then they're charging you to pay it
and you just back off we want people to
be able to move forward and to really
look at these carefully so although I
can I don't want to take up a lot of
your time I can submit my testimony
through the
um to you um digitally but I just wanted
to really look at the situation here
because I think that it's not fair or
reasonable to expect people to pay
additional fees just to pay their bills
and basic Financial Services again like
bill payment should be accessible to
everyone and it shouldn't be such a
disparity now and as technology
technology races away from all of us I
personally I'm going to leave on this
note and just I mean leave my
finish up on this note and that that
note is that I just find it really
overpowering to go and do a
afternoon's worth of and errands if I
stop into six places I have to use six
different machines with six different
people telling me six different ways to
use the one machine they have there I go
into CVS they want my phone number they
want this they want that I have a 90
year old neighbor who doesn't go to CVS
anymore she doesn't want to tell them
everything she doesn't want these paper
doesn't want the trail she doesn't want
anything that goes with the news that we
see all the time that people have been
hacked I've been hacked like five times
I don't even know if I'm getting hacked
and we're all getting hacked right now
so there's no doubt in my mind with
technology today and I'm sorry if I'm
speaking over anyone's head I kind of
consider myself a closet geek and I do
great can you give me an example because
I'm one of these people I love
receipts my result my credit card
companies and everybody always say don't
don't you want to do something for the
environment and get you know and I go no
I like getting my statements and I don't
know I don't have anybody that invoices
me so can you tell me who actually is
like in New Hampshire business that
actually I mean utility what utility
because I mean I I get one day a week
every month I get six different electric
bills all the envelopes and I there's a
lot of paper I have to run through but
yeah getting used to the microphones
again I'm not sure
um
so for me it's T-Mobile right now
they switched over from Sprint Sprint
used to charge you for a paper bill
now they'll charge you for a paper Bill
if you want to have the whole history of
phone calls that you've made that has to
come in a paper bill it's very difficult
to get that kind of history and that
kind of information from the web so
people do ask for the additional
information and they do ask for that
bill to be laid out the way they would
see it on paper and older people are
looking they're converting what we do
today
from what we used to do which is paper
so for this to work for people it has to
be better than paper
part of my argument and part of my hope
that you will look at this again is
basically that yes we do have
environmental concerns I don't like
paper if I can help it I don't use paper
and the reason for that is that it is
not searchable I get 300 million things
that come into my office and I can't
find anything if it's not also digital
and if it's not searchable it's not very
useful to me any longer there are just
way too many details I'm responsible for
in the course of my job that rely on
more and more vendors getting between me
and the job I'm trying to do
I could go on about this forever but I
don't want to over serve myself well the
reason I ask is because I have Verizon
and U.S cellular you know my wife we
have several because I don't like being
on one and uh neither one of them
charges they they send me I get a
printed statement and they don't charge
me for it so the question I would have
is is if there is one that does T-Mobile
maybe that's why they're cheaper than
everybody else is because they're like
Southwest they add charge for extra fee
you know you want those extra things
we're going to charge you for it so that
theoretically all you would have to do
is change the vendor
you know go to go to Verizon or at T and
and or somewhere ever and they might not
would you believe
this is right do I get one too I'm sorry
yeah would you believe me you don't have
to answer the question
in other words I'm posing a
theoretically you might can you can
respond or would you believe you can say
yes or no or or have an opinion
well at it's actually a very good one
why wouldn't the person want to just
change vendors and use a different
service Etc but if you don't have the
technology to do that then you cannot
and then the other thing is so I'm just
going to give another quick thing
a friend of mine is trying to buy an
oven it has this it has that it has this
it has that is Wi-Fi I'm like oh that's
great she wants to know I don't I'm not
up on ovens and what's on them but I
thought it was very interesting and then
a couple days later I was thinking about
it and I was like why didn't I say does
it work without Wi-Fi why didn't I say
that to her I hope she didn't buy it now
by now so I mean we're really looking at
it we're at this point we're at a huge
disadvantage as consumers
so I hope again like I said that this
this bill came through I think this
committee on 13 to 6 in 2021 it was
filed by Sophia wazir twice I believe
before this hearing and I do think that
with a vote like that that I can
hopefully get some people interested in
working on it or at least just looking
at what we're doing now because we have
a lot of problems with our utilities and
when we're I mean I was horrified I was
like what if why would anyone want to
stop me from paying this bill this is
what makes the world go around so thank
you so much if you if there are other
questions
we do brother representative Sullivan
has a question thank you Mr chairman uh
yeah so I have one question I guess I do
use Verizon and they give me I think
it's five dollar discount to be on auto
pay and knocking bills so how would this
bill deal with that situation so if
let's say the base price is going to be
a hundred dollars and they want to
charge 101 or whatever 105 dollars to to
send a paper Bill uh couldn't we just do
it in reverse where the price is 105 and
you get the five dollar discount if you
choose I mean would this bill tackle
that it's not attacked on it just seems
like that to me is the obvious loophole
when I read through this is like oh they
don't want us to charge for it then
we're just going to build it into the
price and then offer a discount if you
choose to do electronic billing or
whatever so I don't know if you thought
about that or a few of us if you have an
opinion of how this bill should address
that or if it should
that is a great question and I'm too
close I'm still learning this and what I
um So my answer to that is this is what
we need to look at because I didn't even
think about that being a reverse
Technique we get five bucks off on
everything for paying it electronically
on time so as far as I think this goes
that might go into a little different
area than this would be because that's
about if you use auto debit or not but
people shouldn't be punished for not
being able to use an automatic debit
I didn't I didn't real I'd never looked
at that as punishing anybody I just
looked at that as like okay if we pay
every month and we promise to be
faithful then we'll get five bucks off
so this is this is just where I'm going
we just have so much going on here and
you have a huge agenda so and with 800
bills I'm hoping that this one gets some
time in front of the legislature and
there's a big floor fight on it when we
figure out what's right and what's wrong
no no thank you so much representative
for the question
Suzanne was my running mate okay uh
we I I the only question I really have
is on the
uh individual agreed by violation of
this chapter shall bring a private civil
action what what was your thoughts on
that what were you trying to get out of
that I mean what did you think a person
could
was aiming to get
as opposed to you know maybe just if
oh
that's a good two bucks time 12 months
before they caught up with you on the
bill
you could assume for 24. how much is
that going to cost you 60 bucks to go
represent um chairman hunt I just want
to make sure that representative spear
was able to complete her question before
my disruption
yeah I I completed it it was just I just
wanted to know what you what your
thoughts were on what that meant you
now I know when when Sophia wrote the
original Bill what this is a refile that
the the what we were looking at was just
to try to get people for to stop doing
it and to reverse it so this really is
not based on any knowledge of criminal
offense or like a civil
under the private closet of action is
the intent to Simply allow for actual
damages or is the intent there to also
allow for the recoup of the Civil
penalties under uh section one above the
the 500 offense or the second daughter
five thousand dollar second offense and
would you please repeat that question
so when if we're an individual were to
bring a private uh class of action under
uh section uh four two would that simply
be to for the actual damages for example
the one dollar fee or they also be
recouping for example the a 500 fee for
the first offense five thousand dollars
for the second offense under section
so I think I can answer this question
under the consumer protection act
we have uh the right uh you know uh
triple private right of action and it's
triple damages so I think they were just
trying to lift that concept
and because this statute is you know is
different and then using that penalty
um then having the fines plus the
penalty uh seems like a little over
overdoing it but that's where the right
right of private action is under our
consumer protection act thank you I was
trying to capture if this was trying to
be a paga or if they were simply trying
to get the uh the actual damages there
yeah oh yeah right which is we are
consumer protection act is supposed to
be which is to make you whole thank you
Mr chairman yeah
look at represent priscelli
I see here it says nothing in this
section shall apply to a government
agency so I don't know do government
agencies charge for
paper billing and why wouldn't the same
section two
thank you I'm not working with line
items that's part of my problem I'm so
a government agency charging you a fee
to do business with them wouldn't be
under the same laws as I would think a
per a private business so it would at
times when the legislation is written it
is added in there where it may or may
not be necessary but it is to guide you
away from thinking that this law is
going to change governmental law and I
can just only give an example
um where I had a bill that went in front
of
um committee to double the time for a
statute of limitations if you had an
injury by pfas in toxins in your water
and that bill was about the statute of
limitations so at that time we looked at
it we wanted to make sure that
everything that we wrote for a town to
be able to take civil action against a
private company wouldn't prohibit
a town to take civil action against a
state and nobody wanted to make that
kind of mistake so thank you for the
thank you very much
thank you so much I appreciate your time
and attention
so uh
uh okay we got Mary Stewart Department
good afternoon
good afternoon I'm Mary Stewart from the
Department of Justice uh consumer
protection and antitrust Bureau and I am
here today neither in support or against
this bill to point out some concerns we
have regarding enforcement which some of
you are also
alluding to
um so to direct your attention to
section U2 Roman numeral one if a person
violates this chapter they will have to
reverse all billing fees and they'll be
subject to a civil penalty of 500 5 000
and 10 000 for the first second and
third offense respectively
um
and it says the Department of Justice
shall be responsible for enforcement of
the statute
so although the statute empowers the
Department of Justice to enforce it does
not Grant the Department of Justice any
powers
to enforce it and the fact that the
statute does not state that a violation
is also is an unfair and deceptive act
under 358a which is our consumer
protection act
means that all our normal investigatory
and enforcement tools available subpoena
Powers assurances
injunctive relief would not be available
to enforce this bill
um which raises the question of what can
the Department of Justice do to ensure
people comply with this
and to that point the statute is silent
in addition the way that it's written
with specific enumerated powers for
private citizens to enforce grieved
individual can get injunctive relief
actual damages attorney fees and costs
but there are no enumerated remedies for
the Department of Justice leaves room
for an argument that the legislature
does not intend to provide those
remedies to the Department of Justice
and for these reasons it's our belief
that this bill in its current form may
be problematic to enforce
so it's our recommendation either that
the legislature states that a violation
of the statute is an unfair and
deceptive act on uh or practice within
the meaning of 358-a or within the
statute itself simply specifically
Define tools available and remedies for
the Department of Justice to enforce it
thank you
any questions or we should just move it
from 359 you just put it under 358a as
one of is an unfair trade practice yeah
a lot of um a lot of statutes uh just
have a phrase that says any violation of
this statute is an unfair and deceptive
act in practice so just puts all those
powers and remedies that are under 358a
yes
yeah
thanks okay questions thank you very
much thank you
okay
Henry V you representing
ctia let me let me see if I can guess
certified tax uh
[Music]
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Henry vayu and I'm here on behalf of
ctia which is the uh Association of uh
Wireless communication uh industry
um back I don't know 10 years ago it was
the cellular technology industry
Association and then they kind of merge
with the internet folks and now it's
ctia the wireless communication industry
so um anyways I
handed uh everybody uh a uh some written
testimony uh on this bill
um and as uh the sponsor indicated this
bill has been before this committee uh
several times and uh in each instance
this in the wisdom of this committee uh
they've not uh centered forward uh and
we hope the committee does the same with
this bill
um
our industry has uh various different
practices uh with regards to paper
billing there's not one size at all so
it does vary but we do oppose uh this
bill uh for a couple of reasons
uh the first reason is that if you want
to avoid uh paying a fee there are
options out there
if you have a cellular phone
you can pay on your cellular phone if
you don't know how to do it on your
phone you can call the Carrier and find
out how to do it and they'll walk you
through how to to pay it if you want to
avoid a fee if they do charge your fee
and as I said it varies across all the
different providers it's not one size at
all and then the other reason for
opposition is the unique uh private
right of action that is in this bill
which you typically don't see in these
kinds of bills which would bring these
kinds of things into the courts which
were already clogged so for those
reasons we oppose house bill 39.
okay any questions or Henry to see none
uh I got one more card left
all right welcome oh hi uh Mr chairman
committee members I speak in opposition
to this bill uh already some things have
already been brought up but I just
mentioned them anyway uh
most businesses are moving to the online
thing it's it's the fact of the matter
is cheaper it saves them money and they
can make their cost to Consumers less so
everybody benefits
um most consumers are actually happy
with this and it's just you know older
ones like me that might be prefer the
old way
um it's basically a user's fee and
actually if they pay the same rate as
everybody else and yet they are causing
more costs with the paper billing and
you have to have an office there then
actually the other people are paying
that it's being shared around so that's
unfair to the people who do the you know
the online stuff which is cheaper
um as was already mentioned you can
always go to other companies if your
company is uh they're doing something
that you're unreasonable there's
different cellular companies there's
even uh like I have you know Breeze line
and you know there's DirecTV and there's
other options so if you're not happy
with what they're charging
you can make a change and that's the
basic thing is why is government getting
involved in this this is not it's
between you and the company that you
deal with there are other options I'm
actually a perfect example on this one
I'm from the old school I like you I
like to write out my checks every month
I want a paper bill and I put my stamp
on it and that's how I like to do it
however like a Brie like let's see the
Verizon that's not an option you have to
have it on your credit card and that's
that so you know it's the best deal for
me right now so I stick with it Breeze
line they actually as was mentioned that
there's a ten dollars credit
as you say they're going to charge you
extra but if for a paper billing but if
you do the online then it's ten dollars
less so you know I do that
um I prefer to do it the old way but I'm
not going to pay 10 bucks extra and
frankly if it bothered me that much I
could go to a different company so
enforcement was talked about so do we
really want the courts and the
Department of Justice involved with this
is such a minor thing where you could go
to some other company or you know I mean
it seems to me the courts and the
Department of Justice should be working
on things like murders rapes uh assaults
crimes of uh property property crimes
that's what
enforcement should be getting involved
but silly things like this like billing
come on it's really silly also what if
you are a New Hampshire resident and you
might get Services goods or services
from a company that's out of state they
don't have a presence here so if this
law passed they'd have to have an office
or somewhere where you could take in
your payment well
New Hampshire small it's a 1.3 million
they might figure the heck with it it's
it's not worth for us to do business in
New Hampshire and New Hampshire
residents who happen to like that uh
service good or service they will now be
deprived of that it's it just wasn't
cost effective for the company to do
that out of state so this will actually
hurt the consumers
um and then lastly somebody mentioned
about the government thing this is like
a double standard
if the rule makes sense you would have
the same rule for everybody including
government agencies too and actually
they do if you try to do like a pay your
property taxes or something they do
normally charge you a fee which kind of
makes sense
uh you're costing them extra and this is
the same idea with paper billing or
having a physical office if you're
costing them extra they're going to make
you pay for it it's not unreasonable
um
and that's it thank you
yeah representative Burroughs I'll say
would you believe
um I think about people like my mother
and mother-in-law who's 95 years old and
bedridden and she ain't gonna learn new
technology
um and for a lot of people like her
three dollars may not be a lot to you or
me but it would be a lot a lot to her
and particularly you know you aggregate
that with other other companies that do
that so I worry about those people and
which is why I really liked
representative Sullivan's idea of giving
people a discount who do the online
thing and that way nobody's penalized
and just wondering what you thought
about that yeah credits are fine as I
say that that's
um it's just another way of doing it I
mean they're going to bump up your price
and then it's like a sales uh you know
half half off whatever but they increase
the price so I understand but the old
people not that spring chicken myself
and as I say I prefer the old way but
you know also you know you could have a
family member help I know some people
they won't do computers or whatever
that's why you have kids and grandkids
could help you with that stuff too
there's always a solution I don't think
government needs to be involved in
making a law on this I I really think
that your neighbor can help you if it's
that bad that's my feeling
and you're like oh yes representative
post
um I just wanted to get your name I
don't know Aubry Friedman uh Bridgewater
private citizen and taxpayer and from
the old school who likes to do it the
old ways but I'm not going to pay even
one dollar I one Buck extra but not ten
like for raised line so I just think
this is silly to have a law on this
okay thank you very much is there
anybody else who would like to testify
on House Bill 39
seeing none I will close the public
actually we have the blue sheet
the blue sheet I can't have
so do we not have the people sign in
online anymore that we had like last
year
because it's supposed to be open open to
anybody okay
uh so we have uh Rick uh
Fabrizio
from Concord of Bia
is hi Rick okay who's uh opposed to the
bill
and Jamie Burdette who just signed in
and didn't say really for or against it
and then Ryan Hale for the New Hampshire
bankers who's opposed to it
and with that I will close the public
foreign
okay
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 73
and hear from the prime sponsor
representative Gallagher
so I I'm Eric Gallagher I represent
conquered Ward 6 which is Merrimack
County District 20. um
and I am here to introduce
House Bill 73
relative to the repair of Home
Appliances which
is a right to repair bill
so
this bill uh
it was here last term
um
it was House Bill 449
in the previous term Dave luno was the
Prime sponsor then but he has decided
that he wants to focus more on education
this term so I'm picking it up for him
um so
basically what right to repair is all
about is
about
when
big Com when big
manufacturers sell you a product
they can't impose restrictions on you
that prevent you from getting it
repaired where you want to
so
which is something that you actually
see happen sometimes so
this is something that has been kind of
gaining momentum recently
you you'll see
that um
the U.S Farm Bureau recently came to an
agreement with John Deere to allow
Farmers to repair their tractors
and in New York
they recently signed a right to repair
Bill to law and then you also had it on
a ballot measure
um
in Massachusetts recently too so this is
a little bit different from some of
those other right to repair attempts
though um
other ones
are well yeah with the tractors one like
farm equipment and then also a lot of
tech stuff
um so like
um computers and
phones and whatever
um but this uh with this bill
when it's focused on other things like
that like
um
the farm equipment or the high-tech
stuff is tended to Garner
a bit more resistance that way so we
have decided
to
try to scale it back a little bit
um you know in the name of compromise
and just keep this too
appliances instead
um
so yeah that's that's why in the title
it says
just home appliances
um
so
yeah
so this is something
that will
help small businesses that are repair
providers like if you looked and saw
um with the Massachusetts ballot
initiative a lot of the
advertisements that were in favor of the
measure were from small repair shops
that want to have
fair treatment
when it comes to being able to
repair things rather than having the
bigger corporations exercise there
Monopoly power to
be anti-competitive
um
so
it's good for it's good for small
businesses it's also
good for inflation too since if you
repair something then you don't have to
spend money on buying a new one and then
that can help bring
prices down
um
which is something
which is something that people are
needing um I I generally try to make my
things last as long as they can
um
you know there's that saying
use it up wear it out
uh make it do or do without uh I think
that's kind of the
spirit
behind this here
so
it's a way of
letting people
do with their appliances as
they want to and
um
so so they can keep money in their own
pop pockets and don't get
if you think about
what
manufacturers do with planned
obsolescence when they make things to
break on purpose so that way people have
to buy a new one every so often that's
basically uh for uh tax being collected
by corporations
from consumers so this is a consumer
protection bill
and
uh it's something that
as someone who tends to break things I I
would
very much appreciate
um I have a
book here called the right to repair if
any of you would like to borrow it to
learn more on the
subject uh I can
lend it out uh
this is something that's
it's supported by
a a wide range of groups such as iFixit
the U.S public interest group the center
for uh Democratic technology
um it's
a good uh pro-consumer bill and I hope
as the
committee with
consumer affairs in your name that you
will give it a fair consideration
um so
that's what I have to say
about the bill so far and I'll take any
questions from committee members okay
Representatives inspired
spear
uh the the I'm not going to try to get
into any details uh we'll have to talk
about that later but what I wanted to
know is what were your thoughts on how
this was going to be enforced since so
many of the manufacturers are out of
state
how did you see New Hampshire
even enforcing something like this
well so if you look at on page three
um
so
on line 31 so 358 T4 remedies so it has
enforcement by the Attorney General so
it basically this would
this would depend on having an attorney
general in office who is
going to bring suit against the
companies which is something you do see
sometimes but the come
state attorney generals will sue out of
state companies at times so that is the
sort of enforcement mechanism that it
representative Burroughs thank you for
taking the question
um so I'm confused I'm looking at the
fit there's nothing on the fiscal note
about costs associated with us and and
clearly if the Attorney General is
responsible for enforcing this it's
going to be time related to his staff
etc etc to do this
so I was wondering if you could could
you know what what is your thoughts
about what the financial costs could be
to implement this well I mean yeah it
says it's indeterminate it depends on
um whether
it depends on
whether the attorney general actually
sues anyone over it or not if all of the
you know you're seeing some companies
that are actually starting to get into
the business of providing more repair
materials to people anyways like just
for compliance with other places that
have right to repair in place so
if there are if they're already in
compliance by the time this comes into
effect then there nobody will need to be
representative
thank you chairman
um representative Gallagher I I read
paragraph one and then I read paragraph
seven and paragraph one indicates to me
that these
authorized repair uh provider has had
some training or gone through some
training
from the manufacturer and again if you
look at has this happened with John
Deere and I know there's been a over the
years a lot of talk about automobile
repairs I mean in order to to get this
information does the manufacturer have
to have uh require some sort of training
for these these folks or can I just put
up a sign and say you know I manual I
repair uh dishwashers and and whatever
with really no training
well yeah it's it mentions having an
arrangement with them like yeah if you
um
you are oftentimes companies will
provide these sorts of trainings like I
remember
um looking into
trying to get my Apple repair
certification a few years ago but didn't
actually go into it um but yeah if you
go into repair shops you can usually
look up on their walls and they'll see
they'll have like their certificates
up on the walls of whatever chaining the
safe done
so that is generally
um how so excuse me just to follow up
for the question being Claire so you are
saying though that this uh
authorized independent repair person has
had some training
under this law and and has been
essentially licensed or approved by the
manufacturer to use their uh product
information
etc etc is that because it looks almost
like one in five one in seven contradict
foreign
is a definition of an independent prayer
provider
it's not
it just excuse me what I should have
maybe said is that seven is inclusive of
um
yeah this is one of those things where
you know if I if I were looking at this
on the computer like you could get it to
generate a difference between the two
but just as a
literally human here um and I'm not a
liar um
so um yeah I
um
I would leave that up to the lawyers to
interpret
representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chairman
um a couple of things occurred to me uh
reading the bill and some of the
supplementary materials that were
submitted to us yesterday
um
it seems that there are some genuine
valid concerns regarding safety and
cyber security regarding
um uh repairs uh done by uh repair
people who are not affiliated or have
not contracted with or been trained by
the manufacturers at the same time it
also occurs to me that it would be
possible to set up a statutory scheme uh
that would
um uh encourage or push Appliance
manufacturers in the direction of
Designing appliances that could be
safely
um
uh repaired by repair people who were
not controlled by the original
manufacturers
um I understand there's a large
incentive in addition to the Safety and
Security concerns there's a large
incentive uh for the appliance
manufacturers to want to control uh the
repair people
um and that it would be possible as I as
I said to have a statutory scheme that
would encourage the manufacturers to
design their appliances so they could be
safely repaired uh by repair people who
are who are not who have not contracted
the original manufacturer but
I want to ask you
um
would you agree that to be effective
this would the statutory scheme would
have to be Nationwide and that trying to
do it
um
just in New Hampshire would be extremely
difficult well
um yes I
my preferred solution would be to have a
national right to repair law which is
something that the buying Administration
has been pushing for through executive
branch rule making but the thing about
executive branch rulemaking is that it's
brittle and
as soon as the
next president comes into power they
could immediately undo those so I think
having state level protections as well
would
be
a good sort of
bulwark or redundancy for
um
back up for in case
the federal government changes things
and you have also seen uh other states
implementing these so
um I
I I don't think
it's beyond our power as a state to do
this sort of thing when we've seen other
states doing it
uh follow-up comment
s
could it be that it's not just a
question of the right to repair but
rather
a system
that would encourage manufacturers to
design
appliances and equipment that could be
safely repaired because I think it is
true that right now there are a lot of
appliances that it would be a problem it
might be unsafe if they were repaired by
repair people who had not been trained
by the original manufacturer but that it
would be possible
if the manufacturers knew that this was
going to be happening on a broad scale
that they would be encouraged to design
appliances that could be safely
repaired by independent repair people
um
I mean yes that's
so all right if to kind of paraphrase or
see if I've got what you're saying so
you're basically saying more of uh
carrot than a stick type scheme of
encouraging of
um that that that is something that I
have had other
um interested parties contact me about
for uh this bill
um
and yes I would be open to an an
amendment that
is
um sorry uh
one further follow-up okay thank you I
um
not so much carrot versus stick rather
than
um
design changes uh which would
they could be encouraged by a carrot or
a stick my point was that it might take
some genuine design changes in order for
um
yes I would support
I I think that this legislation would
encourage those design changes and
um which is something you have actually
seen
some companies do is start making design
changes in response to people asking for
repairability
um
so um
yes if you have an idea for an amendment
on how to do it more that way I would be
open to it but um
I do not have any such Amendment myself
what population
is looking for this action is there do
you think there's a thousand people in
New Hampshire or ten thousand people in
New Hampshire that feel that they don't
have adequate information to fix their
own dishwasher I'm just curious where
are you getting that where are you
getting I I've where's the human cry for
this demand for this insulation
legislation coming from
um the internet uh I I haven't seen much
um I haven't seen much polling about it
if there are any
um pulling
providers out there such as Saint
anselms or the UNH survey that are
watching this that would like to
conduct a poll on this I would welcome
that but um as for my own personal
experience
um it's just
yeah it's it's mostly from the tech geek
community of um
yeah people who like to be in
control of
for the question may inquire so to be
clear there actually isn't any
substantial
demand from
consumers to do this this is a
population of zero I I think the tech
geek Community is a lot bigger than zero
okay
to your knowledge to date how many
jurisdictions have enacted or are
considering rights repair laws in the
United States or the EU
um yeah I don't I am
I don't have a specific number for that
available on hand but yes
um
just the ones I've mentioned so far and
then you also mentioned the EU the EU is
also another one that is considering
this as well I've I heard of some
western states that are considering as
well with the farm machinery
um and John Deere I can't quite remember
which one specifically
off the top of my head but I know it was
some of the western states yeah so
Massachusetts did have a referendum and
it was Otto Just Auto and then the the
most famous case is the John Deere case
and uh and which
um you're dealing with a quarter of a
million dollar
you know hey Baylor machine and the
issue was that you had to have a John
Deere repair person only was allowed to
muck around in it and the farmers were
feeling like we penned we pay you all
this money to buy this thing you know we
can we just go in and fix that and just
sell us apart
foreign
jurisdictions in the EU that are
currently considering or have enacted
this legislation okay that that sounds
that sounds correct to me
um it's within the range that
um
I would estimate yes
but it there is a difference between how
many are considering it and how many
have actually passed it
okay I had been acted yeah it would be
interesting to see what actually has
been enacted I would I would love to see
the the EU or did anybody actually other
than Massachusetts in the John Deere
settlement do you know anybody's
actually Mr Mr chairman uh the EU uh
enacted in 2020 you but I don't know the
results of uh what the weather's
actually gone into enactment yet right
because usually there's a lot of rule
making around well in New York New York
as well um Governor hokel just signed
that
um like on New Year's Eve I think it was
um so
that that's another
case study to look at would be New
York's
fair enough great any more questions oh
representative
we representative ammon's going to be
first because he hasn't asked a question
thank you for your testimony
um there's a YouTube uh personality I
think it's Lewis Rossman
I don't know if you're familiar with
that but he's big on the road to repair
uh so I'm somewhat sympathetic to this
idea that it's harder and harder to fix
things that you pay for and own and you
don't really own them but what I do have
would you believe what I do have an
issue with is the Mandate and my
question is
since we're such a small market and if
we're seen as being too heavy-handed on
companies
do you think that might discourage them
from doing business in our state because
because of the size of our Market being
so small
and that's my question
um
I mean
as far as whether this is heavy-handed
or not I think this is rather milder
compared to some of the other places
that are also considering right to
repair
um if
generally the companies that would be
affected by this
have
the
have the money to be able to
comply with it so
yeah I
I would not be too worried about them
pulling out of New Hampshire
um you know the being small Works kind
of both ways uh like
um
you know it it would only be a small
portion on
of their total um
but it would be something they could
I was just going to answer your comment
on only to let you know that I saw uh
indications that the EU has passed the
legislation and it will go in effect
this year uh this year
and that the UK has passed it and that
Ireland has passed it so and but their
reasoning is a lot to do not just with
repair but because of the fact that
Electronics is something like 200
million tons
in the waste every uh in they quoted a
year of 2017. uh God knows it's probably
worse than that now and they're trying
to use this kind of a bill in their life
to kind of reduce the amount of waste
that's in the environment beside the
fact that people really do want to
repair their stuff and we know from the
car industry that they that they do
people do it all the time
so I just wanted to just clarify that
part so and yeah to follow up on that if
I may um yeah about the waste issue I
think that's another good point to
mention because that was something that
was taught a lot of
um controversy about in the house last
term with
um the safe Forest Lake bill was one
that there was a lot of activism around
um and it was a pretty
um electrifying moment here in the house
when we all stood together to pass
um the save Forest Lake Landfill
sighting bill so
um I think that shows that
um you know there's demand for Less
waste and that this is one thing we
could tell constituents
who are interested in reducing our waste
output that we are doing to reduce our
okay
uh let's see thank you okay
um so
um that's a step down
you're all set thank you
I'm back uh I oppose this one too uh not
as many reasons I just have three three
thoughts on this but after listening to
some of the questions and answers
actually one or two more things to add
basically this kind of a mandate will
increase the cost of these home
appliances and that to me is a problem
um everything is is getting more
expensive these days and obviously these
are not great Economic Times and why
make products more expensive this will
make it more expensive now it is true uh
some people would want to fix their
items and if they can safely without
getting killed or breaking the items
worse that they might I'm actually
thinking this environmental angle and
I've heard it mentioned before is you
your products last longer so there's
less thing you know to there's it makes
sense but if you actually try to repair
it yourself and you ruin it then you
might actually backfire so you know the
idea is good on that but I think for me
personally well I I think there's a
couple ways to go on this first of all
some consumers
ah
might want to fix you know the item
themselves they have some kind of
ability and people like me
I'm not interested I'm going to call the
Maytag Man and that's that
um and I want my cost to be less I don't
want a higher cost and you I don't think
you can deny that if there's this
mandate the costs are going to go higher
so some people might want to actually
pay for a higher price and then be able
to fix it so they'd save money other
people like me I'm not taking a chance
I'd mess it up and it will really be a
disaster so
let the market decide I mean there's
many products out there
um washing machines dishwasher there's
all kinds of and there's you know
different programs available so I just
think making a mandate is not the answer
and it is true items don't last like
they used to I have an old TV but the
tubes and everything I'm not getting rid
of it because I know those new fancy
ones are they don't last that long so
let the consumer decide I think there's
enough variety out there and that also
was mentioned about this and for again
enforcement
I want my enforcement officials working
on real you know as I say murders and
fraud real fraud this is not fraud by
the way uh you buy a product and you
hope it will last many many years but it
may not sometimes it does sometimes it
doesn't maybe you're going to get a
warrant some people get the warranty
program I don't I study it a lot and
then I keep my fingers crossed that I
made the right decision but
um again Department of Justice and all
this this to me should be on real crimes
where there's really an attempt to
defraud and there's this is nothing
about fraud it's just you want your
products I think they have so many
goodies on them now that they
I buy products that have less goodies on
them because the more goodies the more
things they're going to break so
anyway
thank you very much oh we do have a
question representative Sullivan
yeah I just saw a quick clarification So
you you're saying it's going to increase
the cost of our appliances or the cost
of repair
I think if a mandate goes through it's
going to be at it will be an added cost
to when you go to purchase it a
follow-up question for the question
um so what would be the sort of the
channel through which you see the car
like what cost would increase on a
refrigerator that now
the material to fix it is made more
available well
if they have to supply tools I believe
tools are mentioned in here uh
make them available that they didn't
have to before that's something tools I
mean the paperwork isn't a big deal and
most actually appliances now they don't
even really give you the paperwork you
actually have to pull it up online if
you want but tools would actually be
something significant and there's some
question if it's training or whatever
too so uh
it's an extra cost it's going to be
added into the cost of the product I
would say
in Parts two parts was mentioned right
okay great thank you and I have this too
okay and having written testimony
awesome make the court copy
John King
uh representing the association of Home
Appliance manufacturers
oh great you've been here all day
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee my name is John Kent
Association who Appliance manufacturers
also known as aham and women opposition
Hospital 73 we believe this Bill Gates
is more form of safety concerns it seeks
to address
encompasses everything from your
refrigerator clothes washer microwave
electric toothbrush without the pair of
our products include the handling
electricity
refrigerant gases flammable substances
high speed motors in fact appliances are
subject to Electrical Codes building
codes plumbing code safety standards as
well as state requirements to handle our
products
open up the repair process any
third-party have a significant impact on
the safety liability of our products
could you talk slower please
and it opens up the three
oh
I'll go step back a second opening up
the repair process to any third party
could have a significant impact on the
safety and liability of our products
and it opens up the threat to
significant property damage including
the instances we have heard of including
using the wrong refrigerant using
counterfeit Parts leading to leading to
electric shock that's why it is
Paramount to have authors who pay
professional who is trained to properly
hand our products to ensure the customer
remains safe
manufacturers will no longer have the
ability to properly assess with the
technicians entering the home
have met the necessary technical Safety
and Security checks make sure the
customer remains safe
I do want to mention there isn't there
is an issue at home appliance service
repair industry about 20 000 across the
country above those uh shops and 88 of
those are local Mom and Pops repair
shops across the country
um so to conclude appliances are complex
they require training and accountability
untrained repairs can compromise Safety
and Security and as I know State as an
active legislation that cover appliances
up to date with that I asked who to
oppose house supposed to make three
okay any
questions from the committee I guess oh
we do have representative Ammon
thank you for sure could you just please
reiterate you said that no state to date
has passed the appliance provision yeah
so last year
two states in the U.S pass fair to
parallelization Colorado passed a
wheelchair right to repair
and the New York as was mentioned
previously passed the rectory Parable
but explicitly excludes appliances so we
were not it's not part of that law so
what did it cover so I I think it's like
consumer electronics but there is you
can look at the law but the when they
want to make clear about the New York
law is as I mentioned my
um
safety is is highlighted in their law
consumer electronics and only they'll
provide those parts to consumer
electronics only when safety is not
threatened
but we appliances were excluded in that
appliances
Devil's in the details okay
representative post so two questions
um John what was your last name I can't
um and the other one for Colorado you
said that was uh strictly for
foreign
thank you very much
is there anybody else who would like to
okay uh before I close the hearing I
will read the blue says nobody the uh
online we have two support in five in
opposition
and with that we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 73 and say you all
have a safe drive home hopefully the
weather has
together